bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors le personnage
l'imam dicko mahmoud dicko est ce que
c'est une personnalité dont il faut
s'inquiéter ou au contraire qui rassure
pour le mali et c'est renier
merci je pense qu'il faut quand même
leur compte avec la liste mollo cause un
convoi dans l'échelle européenne
traitant seulement 10 col du point de
vidéos du religieux et médicaux et dans
la scène politique malienne depuis très
longtemps bien qu'ils s'en défendent en
partie 2009 ils avaient contesté la
promulgation du code de la famille parce
que j 1 d'islamique et c'était l'heure
des années du président et bk qu'il a
souri pendant avec une amie de son
mouvement islamique donc considérable
aux états unis scolarisation de la
contestation et la contestation n'est
pas religieuse la contestation se fonde
sur des arguments sur lesquels il faut
réformer profondément l'état malien il
faut de la bonne gouvernance il faut
lutter contre la corruption
c'est à dire qu'il est arrivé à un
moment où les lignes politiques cette
date était un manque de crédibilité à la
frustration et devenir des leaders qui
s'est imposée suite à l'échec
les majors syndicaux le symbole même de
l'échec de la classe moyenne dans son
activité
alors c'est vrai que les revendications
la lutte contre la corruption contre
l'insécurité sont des revendications qui
perdure au mali l'imam mahmoud dicko est
ce qu'il a pour ambition de remplacer
ibrahim boubacar kéïta selon je ne crois
pas c'est quelqu'un qui ne cherche pas à
exercer le contrôle et comme il a fait
de la terre avec du métal qu'il tient
toujours co et adam l'obligé parce qu'il
savait saison qui trône connais un haut
conseil islamique
il avait fait changer d'avis mais cas
sur plusieurs docile comme il avait mis
la pression sur l'ancien président arabe
notamment ne pourrai pour retirer au
code de la famille en or des droits des
femmes et je crois que c'est quelqu'un
qui préfère juste
comme l'exercice et il est conscient de
ses limites parce que dans son discours
bien qu'il y ait cette islamisation de
la contestation il n'y a aucun élément
vos propositions
c'est un monsieur aujourd'hui activement
cette grande figure qui commet pas de
voir tous les preuves du manic ça va
proposer une solution
donc je crois que il est l'un des pires
passe d'un côté ou à la révolution
on a presque anéanti la société civile
il s'est imposé un moment comme étant
intelligent qui doit cristalliser les
frustrations et combien ce moment là
maintenant il est central configure dans
la négociation portant sur l'agly comme
pianiste dans le cadre de deux de ses
rayons sur la cohésion nationale 2 comme
il a été aussi très influent quand il
fallait appeler au calme
et aujourd'hui véritablement c'est un
modèle qui si sa prospère au mali avec
un guide religieux en face qui pose
carrément des maîtres au gouvernement
avec de créer d'autres problèmes
pourquoi faire tache d'huile en bovins
paysage inquiète autant puisque nous
sommes dans une ambiance où le sentiment
anti français est très près de lever
aussi bien au mali que d'habitude
l'élément déclencheur de ce mouvement de
contestation contre le président ibrahim
boubacar keita évidemment les
législatives mais aussi on sait la
disparition d'un opposant une grande
figure de l'opposition soumaila cissé il
faut savoir que la lutte domination
d'audi interdit qu est le président etc
a commencé à se détériorer au moment où
la maison est loupé mes gars qu'on
produise pas ce que dit que justement
nous reproche d'avoir mis en place et
milices l'adaqoa d'analysé dans le
centre une amie avec une masse à cana
village abrite cet espace est vraiment
très important
les ja qui sont venus dans une ambiance
non pas pire pour changer véritablement
que la tonne dans une récente étude que
nous avons fait avec la fondation konrad
adenauer sur le rôle des religieux nous
avons montré que ces logements pouvait
véritablement s'imposer en alternative
et du gouvernement ils parlent depuis
2007 l'opposition et que toute
l'opposition et la classe moyenne seront
à se ranger derrière de faire bonne
mesure
je veux dire et ceci est dû à une
politique très corrompu convocations aux
dires de dépôt caquetá il ya quelqu'un
qui avait une opposition qui a fait de
la ccim et qui aujourd'hui parce que la
rue derrière la ligne
alors quelle solution sortir de cette
crise on sait que la cedeao prône
justement le dialogue appel à la retenue
comme l'onu l'union européenne
le président malien a fait des
propositions il a dissous la cour
constitutionnelle
est ce qu'un gouvernement d'union est
possible je crois mais est-ce qu'on
attend pas s'accrocher
certains cas parce que le mouvement
proposé quand même la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale solutions
conventionnelles
la nomination de commissaires à pouvoir
complet qui s'il est bien mettre en
place un président qui serait une
coquille vide
il décale physique à présent mais je
pense que soi qu'on voit aujourd'hui au
mali d'hervé la confrontation et a
commencé depuis vendredi quatre grands
tournois
quand on voit dans le sens du mouvement
ou aussi bien il m'a dit qu'au que
l'état idée car refuser la violence
parce que justement ça pourrait créer
une co op conduire le mali véritablement
vers la situation des années 2011 2012
avec une crise politique profonde
un moment que la capitale et une crise
sécuritaire qui perdure subir au nord au
centre
merci à vous savez je rappelle que vous
êtes directeur du team bouctou
institutes